[Music]
my name is Gabriel Garza Leo I'm a cloud
consultant with the professional
services organization at Google I'm here
with my collaborators from Cardinal
health at Hammond Louise Berthe Zhi and
Walker Miller the way we have structured
our talk today is in four sections we'll
start talking about the challenges and
best practices about application
migrations I'll tell you how ESO the
professional services organization can
help you with application migration
using a methodology called cloud sprints
I'll let you hear directly from Cardinal
else about their experience with cloud
sprint are they use case and then I'll
come back and talk a bit more
technically about what we do with you
when we do a cloud sprint when we start
working with a customer to talk about
application migrations the first thing
we do is assess the maturity of their
infrastructure and there are many ways
to do this but you know one way is
really understanding how much cloud
ready they are and so if you look on the
y-axis there is the on-prem amount of
computation that the customer does
versus how ready they are for public
cloud on the x-axis you can actually see
whether their operations are more you
know classical sysadmin oriented type of
operations versus more cloud native see
ICD base develops operations and of
course you know most customers want to
be on the top right corner but of course
you have a Productivity you have the
portability of the code you know you pay
for what you do but what we often
observe is that customers are actually
on the lower right actually lower left
where everything is more rigid and
expensive and so how can we help a wee
PSO help you move towards the top right
corner here
and of course we work with you to
understand how to integrate your CI
Siddhi processes with with GCP and the
other thing we do is also to help you
with lifting shifting your virtual
machines or your servers from your own
pram environment into GCP so as we do
this we observe that there are
challenges that everybody faces during
these migrations and they're both
business challenges as well as technical
challenges and I mean some of the things
without going through the full list
right but often we put together teams
and then we see that there aren't enough
experts in a given area to actually do
things hands-on on the cloud often there
are decisions that needs to be taken
about the direction of the architecture
and you know there are maybe no decision
makers available at that time to talk to
some concerns about the flexibility of
the design sometimes you know there are
other concerns the way we like to
organize these activities is really as
agile methodologies we are with
iterations of designs and
implementations until we get to a point
where you you want to be some of the
technical challenges is really about the
lack of automation culture I talked
about helping you integrate the icd
processes with with our cloud the closer
you are to you know the right-hand of
the graph the better it is sometimes
there is the idea that you know we want
to do everything all at once and you
know they boil the ocean type of
activity which goes together with the
expectations mismatch on the left and so
as a cloud consult and my job is often
saying let's scope this carefully make
sure that we identify some good first
mover so that we can create an
infrastructure for you and then migrate
into this infrastructure a good
application where you can start testing
things
and you know really popularize the word
that you are doing with us we structure
the journey of a customer through our
service offerings in you know these four
different type of activities we do
assessment we plan with you we talk
about how you can deploy and do the
migration of your applications on the
cloud and once you are there we can
consult on how you can take best
advantage of the cloud with some
optimizations so after you have done a
lift and shift you can start using your
environment already and then you can
start using native cloud services and
you know this is a whole journey that
you know if you if you want the PSO can
help you with and for this talk today
I'm going to talk more about the
foundation so how we design foundation
so for your environment in recipe to
receive your applications and then talk
a bit about how to do the implementation
and throughout this journey we keep in
mind a few best practices that you know
I can tell you about the sooner you have
a production quality foundational
environment the sooner you can start
actually using your crowd for real there
is a lot of focus on our site to really
automate the deployment of foundational
elements and really design in them for
your actual needs in everything that we
do we always consider security first
from you know the first discussion we
have until you know we get to the
optimization phase and really try to
understand not only how to deploy the
foundation in an automated fashion but
also how you can automate the deployment
of your applications as I mentioned
before we organize these activities in
Springs where we can actually do
iterative design and implementation so
that every time you can get a feeling
for how the infrastructure is is going
to
and then I talked about again making
sure that a first mover application the
one that you start moving into your
application to popularize the work
you're doing is a good one it's all
focused a bit in this talk about the
foundational aspect of things and when I
talk about foundational aspects these
are the things that I'm I'm talking
about again selection of first mover
which is the important piece here and
then we want to do user identity either
through G suite or cloud identity
resource organization and access
management go hand-in-hand I'll talk
more about this how you decide to
structure your organization has strong
implications on how you want to
implement policies on this hierarchy of
resources we always recommend using
groups and roles to access resources
I'll talk more about that at the end and
then of course we spend a lot of time
doing that or design so talk about the
connectivity to impress or to another
cloud the topology of the network and on
all the network services DNS and so
forth BGP etc security again we can work
with you to understand your security
objectives and then understand how to
implement proactive security controls
and then what we call reactive security
controls in the sense that we can have
scanners that check your environment
illogically and can fire up alarms when
the configuration is not what you
expected talking about the type of
computing environment that are important
for you and then of course start talking
about operations because at the end of
the day you do your migration but guess
what you're going to have to change
somewhat your operations so to make sure
that you take best advantage of the
cloud now how do we do it in PS so how
can can we help you with this
for application migration so the typical
approach that we take is offering you a
consulting service called the cloud
sprint and the cloud sprint is really a
one-week of intense work preceded by
some preparation where we work together
we do together a workshop for a full
week and we work Albert well go to
design a foundational infrastructure and
start working towards implementing this
infrastructure with you and then migrate
maybe a couple of applications one or
two applications we do this essentially
with identifying the workloads the good
first-mover building the foundational
elements migrating the workload and then
understanding at the end of this week
once we we are off how can we keep
helping you or how can you take this and
you know move it forward by yourself we
talked about GCP and it's a chance for
us to educate you and for us to learn
from you on what you are doing in your
infrastructure security as I said is
always very important in everything we
do select the first mover and then
release time she ate the production rate
the cloud foundation and migrated the
production workloads
when I say production already I'm saying
that all the elements of a production
infrastructure is going to be available
to you it may require still some work to
tailor it to your specific needs so for
example when you do auditing we can
integrate the GCP Logs with your seam
solution you know whether you use plank
or some other solution but of course the
alarms that you want to trigger on are
going to often be application specific
so then when you get to the point of
configuring the new infrastructure to
respond to your needs then you can move
it from production already to actually
production
this is a typical way we organize the
sprints
they are meant to be very parallel
innate in nature and we start generally
with this technical infrastructure
kickoff where we talk about GCP and we
learn from you about your infrastructure
we spend most of the day doing design on
the first day elbow-to-elbow white
morning sessions and then already on the
first day we seek together on your
computers we look at what we have
decided to tackle first of the
foundational elements and then
implemented in DCP with you always talk
about security and then split into
multiple work streams where we each work
streams tackle one of the foundational
elements plus the application
development so the duplication
deployment so the actual migration of
the work flow if you look at the yellow
lines you will recognize the
foundational elements that I was
discussing before one thing that is
important to work well on these together
is that there is a need to have enough
people that are experts in these various
areas in your business so that we can
actually split will bring enough people
enough engineer enough consultants but
we need to be able to pair up the last
day is making an assessment of how well
we did during the workshop and in fact
how ready the infrastructure is for
production activities every day we take
that ideal situation and we reassess it
based on your needs this is a real-life
example of something that we did and we
agree on how to split in groups to
actually accomplish at the end of the
day what we want to do for your specific
needs and this is an example of the
assessment that I was discussing before
you see the two columns the the workshop
outcome and the production already Ness
column how well we did during the
workshop and how ready the
infrastructure is by topic which is
typically the foundational elements that
we have identified for for you
use case one of the best ways we can be
sure that we lower the percentage of
errors in deploying the infrastructure
is by automation we have libraries of
infrastructure as code that we share
with you and we work with you elbow to
elbow to configure so that we can
collaborate on the infrastructure at the
code of your foundational infrastructure
of course the consistency is improved
because you can check this stuff in and
to get and and then you know avoid
manual errors by doing peer reviews
typical debugging techniques that you
can do now on code and of course enforce
policies proactively after this talk
around four o'clock my colleague is
going to talk about more details of this
this infrastructure that we have the
calls foundation and automation it's I
forget exactly we are the hotel the
National Hotel it's not in this building
it's one of the buildings outside what I
can show you is an example of what we do
for example for provisioning projects
I mean creating a project is not
everything you need to to start you need
to then instantiate the computing
environment that you want to use enable
building enable the api's that you care
you know create the service accounts I
am policies and so forth and you can
script all of this by using our
templates now I want to give ad a chance
to talk about their experience with with
DCP
it's the Sun yeah okay my name is Ed
Hammond and I'm with Cardinal Health
Cardinal health is based in Columbus
Ohio Dublin Ohio suburb of Columbus and
our mission is to make health care more
efficient for providers and for in the
end trying to help our patients have
better health care so our cloud
philosophy has been very simple we want
to enable agile teams development teams
to be very effective speed agility cost
efficiency those are all the great
buzzwords traditionally Cardinal health
has been a shared services classic
shared services model where there are
silos of specialists doing specific
tasks and we're trying to break down
those walls and enable agile teams to be
self-sufficient so able to quickly adapt
and experiment with new technologies the
GCP project designed the notion of a GCP
project fits our model perfectly for
doing that because that helps us set up
the security policies and everything for
those agile teams the security by design
we started with building in the controls
right up front what you'll notice right
in GCP is that the project is a unit of
authorization so you can set
authorization controls at the project so
we have tight controls about how we
create projects but beyond that we
delegate the controls to the app dev
teams the self-service and automation is
Gabriele mentioned you want to always
provide tools documentation and
consulting services rather than having a
large shared services team we want to
have a small cloud expert team that can
go around and help DevOps teams be
sufficient self-sufficient in the cloud
so we provide documentation we have a
wiki that has lots of documentation on
it we consult and help people build
things we have a number of colleagues in
the audience that do that
but at the end of the day we want our
teams to be working on their own so they
can really experiment test learn and
grow so how do we do this
one of the key things we learned early
on was that the network is pretty key so
we our design is basically to use to
host projects if you're familiar with
shared V pcs and host projects to use to
host projects one for production one for
non production and create shared V pcs
under that then the project teams are
using service projects that consumes
those V pcs we have tight controls over
internet ingress and egress patterns
we're using various different security
appliances and techniques for doing
those kinds of things but we we worked
very hard at setting that up up front so
before the cloud sprint engagement with
PSO who did a great job by the way we
had all this set up it took us about
three months working with our account
team to learn how it all worked because
we went from zero knowledge to three
months we had it all built ready to go
and we started going into the sprint our
application teams manage their own
projects again typically they'll have
one service project for production one
service project for non production and
then we set up the I am roles custom I
am roles at the organizational level and
we delegate that down and use service
counts and eighty groups we map them
over for owner and editor privileges
when they need to on the projects the
service counts for V PC firewall rules
that's really key to us so that when you
create an instance its using a service
account and that gives the authorization
for that instance we're also doing it
for routing rules so it can do the
ingress egress patterns as well as for
the V PC firewall rules for east-west
and north-south traffic as gabriele inch
and mentioned we always want to have
everything scripted so wherever
something is well known well understood
and repeatable we try and do it in
script in scratch
so when we built the networks our
project creation process is all scripted
creating service counts and so forth
those are all scripts that we use with
that I'm gonna turn you over to my
colleague los Pharisee who is a cloud
evangelist so they let us make up our
titles when we were doing this
presentation so I thought about what I
do on a daily basis and my official
title is a senior engineer but I feel
like my job at Cardinal Health is really
making sure everyone understands what
the benefits of the cloud are and what
they can achieve in the cloud so that's
that's where I came up with the cloud
evangelist title I want to tell you a
little bit about our sprint engagement
and how that experience was for us and
there's really two messages that I want
to share with you that I want you to
take from this the first is to be ready
or be prepared going into your sprint
engagement and the second is to view the
sprint really as as taking you the last
mile into your journey in the cloud so
obviously Google's going to meet you
wherever you are in the process so if if
you you're on the first mile don't feel
like it's not time to engage but for us
really it was taking us the last mile
really helped out a lot so plan ahead
understand the technology play around
with the services we had we had four to
five engineers that were researching
Google technologies in the two months
leading up to our sprint kind of talking
about our culture how the Google
technologies how we wanted the Google
technologies to fit in really how we
wanted to to design overall and so by
the time we by the time the PSO
engineers came on site we had a lot of
our design complete that allowed us to
to vet a lot of our designs and make
sure
that we were thinking about all the
things that we should have been thinking
about that we weren't leaving anything
out that we weren't being stupid about
some stuff and so that was it was really
helpful for us so I'd encourage you if
you're starting if you're early on in
the process to do some research on VPC
strategies cloud identity resource
hierarchy and custom roles those were
those were some key areas that that we
understood where we wanted to be when
the PSO folks showed up so that we could
we could make the most progress as
possible so being prepared allowed us to
get into details like how to how to
deploy and configure for SETI building a
billing shobak model and data studio
defining our organizational policies so
it was still in alpha when when we
deployed but organizational policies
really allowed us to feel much more
comfortable about giving out the keys to
projects because we could still put some
controls in place right we could put a
policy on saying no one can create a
resource with public IP addresses
because I don't know about your at your
company but our security folks aren't
very keen on workloads that should be
internal having public IP addresses we
were also able to integrate our
organizational stack driver logs into
Splunk we also ran multiple work streams
in parallel so we had several conference
rooms that were dedicated to the sprint
engagement and we had sub teams that
were breaking off it was it was a lot of
planned chaos for the week that they
were on site with all the things that we
had going on but it was great to be able
to make a lot of progress in a short
period of time with that kind of gets us
into one of the use cases so we we had
four application teams
that we are able to bring up on GCP
during the week of our engagement that
that had never used Google cloud
platform before and like we like Edie
was saying we wanted self-service we
want automation we want we want
application teams to be able to do
things themselves so when when those
application teams they had support that
we were in the room we had Google in the
room but but our attempt was which we
were successful at was giving the
application teams the tools they needed
to deploy their own resources not to
have us to deploy the resources to have
them script out their application
installs so that they'd have
repeatability so one of those teams was
our Splunk infrastructure team so we
Cardinals been in the cloud for a few
years now our Splunk infrastructure was
on another cloud platform for many
different reasons we wanted to move that
into Google so during the sprint
engagement we we moved our dev
environment from from another cloud
provider that that likes the color
orange into into GCP we we at the end of
the Sprint they had built deployment
manager scripts for their whole stack
they had migrated subsets of their data
from over into GCP so that they knew
what they were doing when they got to
production they're moving subsets of
sample data and and really prepared
themselves for a successful production
migration the following month so Splunk
was the first production application we
had running in GCP about a month after
our engagement it also laid the
foundation for them to be able to
explore an elastic environment so in our
in our prior cloud provider there wasn't
this concept of projects there's a count
but you can't easily manage hundreds or
thousands or thousands of accounts so it
was a multi-tenant environment people
didn't have the ability to spin up their
own resources because it if you gave
them
just spin up and delete their resources
they could spin up and delete other
people's resources - not a good thing so
GCP allowed them to build an elastic
infrastructure so as they need to add
resources they can add resources they
don't need doing clay engage a cloud the
cloud team to add resources to their
environment
they modify a script and and execute it
and and they have more indexers or more
search heads since like I said since we
could delegate more permissions they're
able to explore and improve upon their
processes rather than be dependent on a
centralized team to do everything for
them so that was our experience with
with the Google sprint engagement and
really you know like I said before
Google met us where we were at so if you
if you feel like like you're not sure
where to go they can get you to where
you need to go if you feel like you've
got a good plan but you want a little
bit a little bit of backup make sure
that that someone that's done this
before is making sure that you're not
doing something stupid it was great for
us it it really was effective for Google
to be able to meet us where we are at in
our lifecycle I've engaged that I've
engaged many vendors in my years in IT
and I do have to say that that the
Google professional services folks are
far and away more experienced and more
knowledgeable than any other vendor that
I've brought professional services in
for so it was definitely an awesome
experience for us
and with that I'm going to turn some
time over to walker miller who's going
to talk to you about our efforts with
containers during the sprint thanks
see this one
all right so probably like a lot of
enterprises out there we got to go
forward strategy of utilizing kind of
for in-house development a combination
of paths and faz as kind of our first
approach but when you look at Cardinals
compute frame rate footprint we're
really about only about 15 percent
internally to developed applications we
have about 85 percent common
off-the-shelf software and obviously we
can't do a lot with that as far as
trying to determine you know what we
think might be a best practice for it we
have limitation what we've kind of
identified is is probably the biggest
possibility for all that stuff is to
move them into containers in kubernetes
we see a lot of cost optimization and
just a lot of benefits that you get from
living in kind of a container world with
consistency speed etc right so but as
part of that we have very limited
experience when it comes to containers
and COO Bernays we've had some success
in the past world but that's largely
because they build the containers for
you and we don't have a team to really
support or do any of that so we get to
we get to kind of start from scratch and
and so it was pretty easy for us to
choose to kind of partner with Google
very early on to help us kind of build
that muscle and so we brought them in
for that first sprint which was about a
week long we had a track that was 2 days
and we just said let's let's get a
container done right and that's what we
started with was just just one so we
took kind of what we identified as some
of our container friendly partners in
our case we focused in on IBM and their
WebSphere stack WebSphere application
server web server message broker and
WebSphere MQ are all things that work
pretty well in a container world and IBM
has a good level of support for so we
weren't just kind of out on a limb on it
nobody's too excited about using those
technologies anymore but you know they
still exist for us and they're not going
to go away unfortunately any time soon
so we took the first apps and within 2
days we were able to get one of each of
those up and running
and again we had one you know one person
from each of those teams internally
working with Google and neither of them
had none of them had done anything with
containers before so that sprint ended
up being you know as much as we could
get done in two days we did we had a
good idea for what the process would
look like however you're only gonna make
so much progress in two days so we
brought Google back for an additional
month to focus in on just the Western
application server stack and our goal
with that was to get five to eight
applications done and we did and really
what we wanted to focus on was building
a factory so we you know West fear
applications are pretty cut and paste
for the most part once you get it up and
running and we wanted that full-blown
kind of pipeline that we could use to
build our containers and so Google came
in helped us out and we were able to by
the end of that month long we had a
factory we had five applications up and
running at least one of them fully
tested and we had more importantly had a
pipeline so since they've been there
we've actually gotten an additional six
applications that are up and running
including in our e-commerce application
which is our big bread-and-butter right
so and that's a full-blown Webster stack
I won't go in the detail
so it was very very very successful for
us yeah that's it
I'm good back to you Thank You Walker
all right very good
so I wanted to spend the remaining time
I have to talk a bit about the type of
decisions you need to take when you go
on implementing your automation for the
provisioning of the foundational
elements has talked a bit about the use
cases on the twerking and Louis's
mentioned some of these elements I
wanted to spend a bit more time on these
four on the board the bold ones so
selection of the first mover I mentioned
that it's important there are some
business characteristics and some
technical characteristics of a good
first mover if we talk about the
business characteristics you want
something that is not really business
critical for your first example but on
the other hand it shouldn't be an edge
case you want to use this first mover as
the way you go back to your executives
saying look we have migrated X and this
is important to us let's make sure that
now that we have migrated X so we can
migrate everything else and you get
support because of the important of
importance of X you can actually then
build a knowledge base is out of this
experience and then of course you know
it can afford the cat over in window etc
etc doesn't have compliance challenges
ideally on the technical side you want
something that is really not very
dependent on other services as you start
moving the application to the cloud you
don't want to have to take everything
else that comes with it you know it may
be it has less integration with gzp
services and so on so forth
I mean pictorially if you look at you
know a design diagram like this maybe
that that box at the right box may be a
good first mover doesn't have a lot of
dependencies with other things so maybe
can be deployed with the ICD techniques
and maybe this one is not so good
because of you know the way it depends
on everything else what we do we go
through diagrams like these with you
when we help you select what a good
first mover is
the resource organization and access
management now Louis was mentioning
before that they were implementing
security policies for example to prevent
the provisioning of public IPS now this
is what you want to think about when you
want to then implement security and
access policies the resource hierarchy
allows you to do good separation of
duties it allows you to implement the
access and security policies building
isolation is at the project levels and
then you can control Quora
and limits through this hierarchy and
generally what we recommend is well
let's start thinking about the simplest
infrastructure we can design for you and
you know this is actually a very simple
one where you have projects and then you
put them together into folders that are
environment specific now each one of
these nodes in this hierarchy is a place
where you can actually implement access
and security policies so you can say
well in in the dev environment I'm not
going to have my developers provision
public IPS but maybe on production I do
need public IPs and so you can change
the policies that way now this is simple
but in this example for example where do
you place your shared services and so
then maybe you can think about something
that is a bit more complex where you
maybe still retain the environment
oriented approach but then you maybe
have something that is you know shared
services oriented and you know this is
good it's enabled a separation for
shared services it preserves your
environment separation but you know the
drawback is that it's more complex than
before and maybe you need still
something more complex because you know
for example if you have multiple
business units what are you going to put
them and so we can go on in the
discussion and maybe you can add another
layer you can have at the top the
business units and you end up having
something that is pretty granular for
your access controls you know it's
easily extensible you have a
a new business unit that you want on
board it's easy to do you know it's a
complex structure so it comes with
complexity the fact that then you have
to manage your groups or your roles very
carefully and also the network topology
if you have a say one project that
manages your network then you want to be
careful about how you give permissions
to other folders in the structure and
you know the projects inside those
folders to get access to the network
so together we generally all go through
through something like this some
discussion like this and and then decide
which one is the best hierarchy for you
together with the hierarchy as I
mentioned goes access management so how
is access management implemented in
Google if you look at this diagram here
you have that you have identities at the
top you have individual identities Robo
identities so service accounts and then
you have groups groups can be a
collection of those two these identities
are granted a role and they're all is a
set of permissions over resources what
we recommend always is that you give
accesses to your resources draw or role
to your resources from a group because
this way it's easier for you to manage
the membership you know if people come
and go you have a structure that is well
thought out of and to the zeros level
what we recommend is to start simply
with maybe for organizational level
groups we have the orchid mean you know
defines the IAM policies you can
implement the structure that we have
discussed before can create projects
although eventually maybe this
responsibility can be delegated you have
a network administrator group that has
the responsibility for creating the
network topology that then the rest of
your environment is going to use the
network administrator's in this picture
maintain the federal rules and
you know you can decide whether this
function is something that the network
administrators do or the security
administrators do that's part of the
discussions that that we're going to
have you have a security administer
sources establishes the role so the
custom roles that Lewis was talking
about before and then establishes the
policies at the organizational nodes of
the structure that we were discussing
before and then you have somebody that
is responsible for setting up the the
building accounts
monitoring the usage granting access to
using the billing account to project
owners and so on so forth so you know
these are what we recommended as a
minimum for organizational level and
then of course there are folder and
project level groups and these actually
change a lot depending on your business
you always have some kind of reliability
engineer or you know some kind of
developed operation where the developers
develop in an environment and then
collaborate with the reliability
engineers to actually do the deployment
through the ICD and then you have you
might have some kind of data analyst
figure that you know you want to to
create a group for now for every one of
these groups we recommend a set of rules
and as I said these rules are sets of
permissions on to the resources so in
this example I have only one example you
have the compute network admin that
creates modify and delete networking
resources you know except for firewall
rules and SSL certificate you know as I
said before you can decide whether to
give that permission to the network
administrators or your security
administrators and so on so forth now
one thing that we also do start talking
about operations once you have
disability foundational layout you have
your application in your environment you
need to make make sense of it and
operations has multiple facets one thing
that I thought I'd talk about with you
is really the building and analytics one
thing that we always recommend is make
sure that when you create your in your
organization you go to your account
billing account and you export the logs
to be query this allows you to do at
least two things one thing is you can
use SQL syntax to query your your
billing information and so you can start
having insight and your billing
information the other thing you can
deploy out-of-the-box they study data
studio dashboard that can display
information about your building so that
as you configure this these dashboards
you can create automatically reports so
that maybe you can share with your CFO
or your with your VPS key to doing good
building is really defining the labels
that characterize your resources so
labels can be for example associated to
cost cost centers maybe to business
units when we PSO come on site with you
we have that discussion with you right
how should we organize the labels to
view your building at a minimum you have
the granularity of the project level but
automatically things like data studio
this dashboard can pick those label and
create reports for you and the way to do
it you know there are instructions on
how to do it and we go together over
these instructions and create a data
studio dashboard for you now these are
the few things that I want you to pick
out of you know everything we do in
short what we have discussed is that
lift and shift is a good way together
with you know integrating your CI CD
processes to modernize your IT
infrastructure PSO can help you with a
methodology called
cloud sprint it's a one week of work you
have heard from Cardinal ELLs their
experience using Sprint's and working
with us and then you want to automate
everything that you do for creating your
foundation and deploy your applications
and we discussed the some of the concept
one needs to go through to really
implement these design concepts in
infrastructure as code
[Music]
you